yeah we're starting with a complete
closure of Northbound i-11 because this
has been there for more than an hour
coming up on two hours this is an
overturned tractor trailer now they do
have a giant tow truck on scene other
specialty equipment coming from the
Nevada Department of Transportation
there was a 40 gallon fuel spill let's
take a look at it from the other side
Northbound i-11 completely shut down
this is going to be backing up into
Boulder City they are getting you off
here at Wagon Wheel once again the rest
of the freeway system not too bad but
North on i-11 all lanes are closed
because of this tipped over tractor
trailer again a tow truck is on scene
not a bad detour as they get you off at
Wagon Wheel and you go right on Boulder
Highway so expect big slowdowns there
but you can see the Northbound i-11
backing up into Boulder City we don't
know how long it's going to take to get
it cleaned up but we'll be watching it
for you